♪♪
>> OH, MY GOSH.
SHOULD WE HAVE BROUGHT FOOD?
I DON'T KNOW HOW THESE THINGS
WORK.
>> HONEY, IT'S YOUR FIRST
REUNION.
IT'S FINE.
MY FAMILY LOVES YOU.
>> REALLY?
THEY LOVE THAT YOU MARRIED A GUY
WHO WAS LL BEAN'S CUSTOMER OF
THE YEAR?
>> YES, JUST BE YOURSELF.
>> ALL RIGHT.
ALL RIGHT.
HELLO, EVERYBODY.
I JUST WANT TO WELCOME YOU ALL
TO THE ROBINSON FAMILY REUNION.
YES, INDEED.
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE A GOOD
TIME.
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE A GOOD TIME
TONIGHT, ALL RIGHT.
OKAY.
I WANT EVERYBODY TO GET OUT ON
THAT DANCE FLOOR.
COME ON.
IT'S TIME FOR "THE CUPID
SHUFFLE," Y'ALL.
>> OH, MY GOSH.
EVERYONE'S WEARING T-SHIRTS.
DID YOU KNOW ABOUT THIS?
>> YES.
THEY DIDN'T SEND YOU ONE IN THE
MAIL?
>> COME ON, Y'ALL.
♪ IT DON'T MATTER
IF YOU'RE YOUNG OR OLD ♪
♪ WE GONNA SHOW YOU
HOW IT GOES ♪
♪ TO THE RIGHT
TO THE RIGHT ♪
♪ TO THE LEFT
TO THE LEFT ♪
♪♪ NOW WALK IT BY YOURSELF.
♪ YEAH, WALK IT
BY YOURSELF ♪
>> HOW MANY FAMILY MEMBERS DO
YOU HAVE?
I FEEL LIKE THEY'RE ALL LOOKING
AT ME.
>> OH, GOD, THEY'RE NOT.
I PROMISE.
♪ TO THE RIGHT
TO THE RIGHT ♪
♪ TO THE LEFT
TO THE LEFT ♪
♪ TURN AND DUNK
TURN AND DUNK ♪
♪ NOW PUSH IT LIKE LeBRON
YEAH, PUSH IT LIKE LeBRON ♪
>> YOU KNOW, I'M NOT SURE I KNOW
THIS VERSION OF "THE CUPID
SHUFFLE."
>> OH, THIS HERE IS THE "ATLANTA
TWO PIECE IN A BISCUIT REMIX."
♪ SOMETHIN' STINK
SOMETHIN' STINK ♪
♪ YEAH, FOLD YOUR TUPPERWARE
YEAH, FOLD YOUR TUPPERWARE ♪
>> YOU KNOW, I HAVEN'T SEEN
ANYONE I RECOGNIZE YET EITHER.
>> DANIEL!
YOU'RE HERE.
>> TANITRA, HEY.
YEAH, I'M HERE, WITH MY WIFE.
THIS IS LISA.
>> OH, HEY, LISA.
I THINK WE COUSINS, GIRL.
BUT, SEE, ME AND DANIEL, WE OLD
FRIENDS.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
WE USED TO PLAY ALL DAY AS KIDS.
WE JUST HAD TO BE HOME WHEN THE
STREET LIGHTS CAME ON.
>> THAT'S IT.
HOW IS THAT HOTEL YOU'RE STAYING
AT?
>> IT'S PRETTY NICE.
BUT THEY DIDN'T GIVE US A WASH
CLOTH.
>> WHAT?
WHO SHOWERS WITHOUT A WASH
CLOTH?
>> I KNOW.
THEY NASTY, DANIEL.
OKAY -- ARE WE STILL GOING TO
ESTON-FEST THIS YEAR?
>> I RESERVED US TWO SEATS FOR A
LIVE TAPING OF "I WANT TO FIX MY
LIFE."
>> OKAY, BET.
I'M BEHIND THAT SHOW, OKAY?
I GOT TO MAKE SURE THEY KEEP
THAT DOOR CLOSED.
OKAY?
>> YEP, YOU CAN'T LET THAT GOOD
AIR OUT.
>> WAIT, WAIT.
NOW YOU'RE GOING TO ESTON-FEST?
>> OF COURSE.
I GOT YOU A TICKET, TOO.
♪ CALL THE COPS
CALL THE COPS ♪
♪ THEY'RE GONNA BE A WHILE
THEY'RE GONNA BE A WHILE ♪
♪ PLAYING BASS
PLAYING BASS ♪
♪ YEAH, HOW MANY
BOOKS YOU GOT ♪
>> WAIT.
YOU BROUGHT CARDS?
>> LISA, OF COURSE.
IT'S A FAMILY REUNION.
>> OH, THERE HE IS.
I HEARD YOU WAS HERE, DANIEL.
>> NOW IT'S A PARTY.
>> OH, DANIEL.
>> WAIT, WAIT, NOW.
YOU KNOW MY UNCLE BUCK?
>> OH, YEAH.
BUT I KNOW HIM AS MR. ROBINSON.
HOW'S YOUR KNEE DOING, SIR?
>> OH, BETTER.
I PUT A LITTLE ROBITUSSIN ON IT.
>> WORKS EVERY TIME.
IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU HERE.
I WASN'T SURE IF THAT COVID
WOULD KEEP YOU AWAY.
>> WELL, I GOT VACCINATED, BUT
DON'T TELL NOBODY.
>> I HEAR YOU.
I GOT VAXED, TOO, BUT IT WOULD
BREAK MY MOMMA'S HEART IF SHE
KNEW I TOOK A GOVERNMENT NEEDLE.
>> NOW I HEAR THAT.
UH-OH, I GOT TO GO DANIEL.
THEY GOT ME WATCHING MY LITTLE
NEPHEW.
HE ALWAYS ACTING UP.
>> THAT'S CHILD PROBLEM IS HE'S
GOT NO HOME TRAINING.
>> AND HE NEEDS TO STAY OUT OF
GROWN FOLKS BUSINESS BEFORE HET
GET WHIPPED!
>> SEE, DANIEL.
I TOLD YOU EVERYBODY LOVES YOU.
>> AW, COME ON.
I ONLY KNOW LIKE 20, 30 PEOPLE
TOPS.
♪ TO THE RIGHT
TO THE RIGHT ♪
♪ TO THE LEFT
TO THE LEFT ♪
♪ GONNA FIGHT
GONNA FIGHT ♪
♪ NOW RUB SOME VASOLINE
YEAH, RUB YOUR VASOLINE ♪
>> ALL RIGHT, GREAT JOB,
EVERYBODY.
AND NOW IT'S TIME FOR THE "SOUL
TRAIN" LINE.
>> OH, MY GOSH.
I DIDN'T KNOW THIS WAS
HAPPENING.
>> HONEY, LISTEN, YOU DO NOT
HAVE TO DO IT, OKAY?
>> YEAH.
NO, I DON'T THINK IT WOULD BE
APPROPRIATE.
BUT --
♪ NOW, WALK IT BY YOURSELF
YEAH, WALK IT BY YOURSELF ♪